Let's see where else we want to go today.
There's just all sorts of different people here.
Let's go. Oh, I want to hear from from Brooklyn.
Let's go to Mo from Brooklyn, Mo. How are things
there? I was seeing some of my Brooklyn friends
posting videos of double lines around voting
buildings, like the line goes around once and then
there's it's like a concentric line around that.
Yes, absolutely. It is really. I'm happy to see
so many people waiting in line. I mean, recently,
a few days ago, I actually voted in Brooklyn.
Yes, in Brooklyn College. And the line was pretty
big. I make sure to get it kind of around where
the polling places closed. Yes. Because I knew
that the turnout wouldn't be would kind of go
away near the end. You know, people are leaving.
And it was it was a cool thing.
Now you're talking Brooklyn
College. Is that you're talking about
like a near borough hall, right.
Near bar? Not exactly. Oh, OK.
It's on campus road near full at
the corner near Fabrício.
I'm thinking of Brooklyn Law
School. Sorry. Okay. Yeah. Flatbush, OK.
Yeah. So in that neighborhood right now,
are things are things relatively open or is
there still stuff that's shuttered altogether?
Oh, no. Things are very open, very hogar.
Yeah. I mean, yeah, I mean, they obviously
are operating very safe, of course, but things
are open nonetheless. But I actually didn't have
a question. I just want to tell you something,
please. Is that is that your repetition of telling
people to vote? It has worked on me. Really. See,
I was I was in New York. And of course, Biden is
going to win New York in a landslide. Yes. But
because I'm I'm on the David Pakman. Spread it up,
read it a lot. A lot. Right left leaning
celebrities. And I hear you know, I see a lot
of means posted about vote voting, for example,
on the Steven Kennedy guest. And you, Bernell,
the second cell credit on the Bloche Subrata and
on the day David Pakman. So read it. Right. And
seeing all these, Meems has actually convinced
me to go vote. So this is actually something.
And this is something that Trump actually knows
is that if you say so, if it's like repetition
is important when delivering a message. Yes.
Maybe reload and repeat it rather than lies.
But it is true that repetition works. I
think we should repeat truth like everybody
should vote rather than lies. But yes, I
think Trump and I both understand that.
Yes. And that's what I want to say, man.
All right. Well, I'm glad you voted.
Let's hope for a blow out in New
York. I believe we will get it.
Yes. Absolutely. All right. Thank
you so much. Great to hear from you.